[Applause]
[Music]
question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are going to ask me and
tara questions and we're going to answer
them
and it's going to be fun like a party
which is why it's called you know a
question party yeah
so if you have a question just raise
your hand and if we call on you stand up
and ask it ask it nice and loud so that
we can hear you but do not pull your
mask down
we're trying to answer questions and not
spread germs okay let's do this who's
got a question for me and tarek the
first guy i saw is blue shirt way in the
back
that's i said way in the back you are
very in the front but oh no
we're going to get both of them front
blue shirt you shout it
and what's your
best joke when did you know that you
were funny and what is your best joke
i knew that i was funny when i was i
don't know the if i had google i could
answer it like um uh there is a a guy
named johnny gill
who
yeah it's a very good song um and when
we were at the movies with my older
sisters they were like trading barbs
with this group of guys they were just
ragging on each other and
i uh the guy who was ragging on them
looked like johnny gill and i was like
let's go you guys because this johnny
gill looking bug rubs me the wrong way
and that's my best
that was my first very good laugh that
that's a that is so
you it's so beautiful
uh i think for me i was in high school
and um you know i was in a bunch of i
was in like played sports and was in
theater and i did a bunch of clubs and i
was in black student union
and my school was in the suburb and they
decided to have like this contest where
all the guys from every club would
compete and it was a stupid contest
called mr spiffy
and
the black student union was trying to
figure out which of the guys was going
to go
and so my buddy was this really funny
guy named jay jones and everybody was
going to vote for him and this guy
eugene i'll never forget it interviewing
he was like no
we can't vote for jay we gotta vote for
tarik and everyone was like why it was
like
tax funding to both black and white
people
thank you for your questions we loved
having you here that's all the time we
have for question party this was great
should we do it again sometime
all right everybody
[Music]
you